[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at Nate here and today we are doing
something super crazy we are making the
stinkiest the raunchiest catfish bait
ever and I'm using my wife's blender now
luckily she's got home today otherwise
she would murder us for this but we've
got some fermented shad guts and chicken
livers and wait do you hear that yeah
bunghole we're dead we got get out of
here
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys I'm home
what's that smell look Luke Nathan why
are you guys well things are a little
hot back at the Nichols house and it's
gonna be a couple days before they flow
over now we can't use any credit cards
or go to a hotel because Beca contracts
that so we're gonna go off the grid for
a couple days and to do that we got to
use just what's in our bug-out kids
let's go all right guys we finally found
a good hiding place we were hearing a
little floodplain by the river that
could we'll never think to look for us
here but the downside is it's a bit
swampy the ground here is really muddy
see here it's really wet and we don't
have a tent in our bug out bag we don't
have sleeping pads either so we got to
find a way to stay warm stay dry and
stay out of the mud because it's gonna
get down into 20s tonight
it was raining pretty good this morning
so everything's pretty wet so I'm trying
to find a bit of driest ground all right
I guess this is good a spot as any it's
muddy so we're gonna have to figure out
some way to deal with that mud or inch
is not gonna work I know a lot of you
guys are wondering why are you sleeping
in a mud hill but that's just what we
got this is a spot we have available to
us that's the thing you got to learn to
adapt so we're gonna give that a go
well it's been raining for the last two
days and everything is wet the mud is
just wet the wood is wet and right now
it's in the 40s it's not so bad but the
winds kicking up it's supposed to get
about 15 mile-per-hour winds from the
north and push in a lot of cold air and
it's gonna get down into the 20s
[Music]
well during this campout I'm also going
to do a review of some survival shovels
and I'm gonna try them all out and see
what works and what doesn't work all
right so I got all the mucky clay
scraped off and down to a relatively
drier stuff this would be a terrible
idea if we were expecting any rain
because it would just become a swimming
pool but we aren't expecting any rain
and so hopefully this will work out I've
got a little fire pit there with a
little heat reflector which is designed
to reflect some of the fires heat back
towards us and since it's covered in
clay hopefully it won't catch on fire a
lot of wood heat reflectors do that and
we got just a little bit of a berm here
which I'm hoping will help keep the wind
out but we don't have a lot of thin
little pieces of timber to cut down and
lash together we've got tons and tons of
dead wood so I think we're gonna build
something that looks a little bit more
like a beaver lodge and less like a
lean-to
[Music]
a lot of these survival shovels claim
you can use them as axe but this one
works the best by far what do you think
so far bud this is cool
that one's your favorite yeah
this right here's my kama it's a
Japanese hatchet I bought in Kyoto this
summer and it's just razor sharp I'm
really enjoying it originally I had a
crosspiece in between these two fork
sticks and I was gonna have like a
slanted roof but I was thinking it's
gonna let too much air flow in in
between the walls and the roof too much
of a gap and so instead I think I'm
gonna do is just build the roof straight
onto these walls and then the roof will
be quite low to the ground and I think
that'll help conserve the heat you know
keep it warmer in there a little bit
better and then I need to also Oh get
some smaller sticks and some mud and
fill up all the gaps in the walls here
well the Sun setting and Nathan's
getting a little cold and hungry so
we're gonna go and start a fire here
with my flint and steel and see how that
goes
these are just ordinary cotton balls no
Vaseline or anything
[Music]
well the real trick with this is you got
to build the fire up and get the heat
into the shelter without getting all the
smoke so hopefully we've built it right
well we'll give it a kind of a test run
here and see if it works well this is
really our first time doing this type of
camping I've done a lot of snow cave
camping up in Alaska but I've never
never done this so I'm kind of curious
to see how it goes but that fire sure is
nice it actually radiates quite a bit of
heat into the shelter and the shelter
blocks the wind and kind of traps the
heat but I'll tell you what though this
clay is super cold and that and all the
heat in me is just getting sucked into
the clay so I've got to figure out
something to insulate us otherwise we're
gonna freeze sitting on this icy cold
clay Nathan are you hungry I'm super
hungry so I think we need to do some
cooking here good
that looks pretty good keep this thing
moving around
well this rump roast is looking pretty
good it's getting all juicy but I think
Nathan just really wants to cook hot
dogs I might be overthinking this that
right all right let's get you a hotdog
stick why don't you spin your hot dog
yeah good job good job just spinning
every once in a while doesn't it you
don't have to always spin it this with
my boy cooking some food and and doing
some camping I just wish Tommy was here
wait do you hear something tell me I'm
glad to see you man but why are you here
did you put the raccoon in the house
[Music]
wait wait Tom did anyone follow you were
you followed
were you followed no you sure about that
you sure mother can't find us oh I love
you so much you are a wonderful wife I
was never at the house I've been camping
the whole time
Nathan do you want a bun
Jacob you having fun you like champions
yeah what do you think babe looks great
sure buddy yeah
Oh will you that we got some garlic
bread there we go looking good
just keep shaving pieces off snuggled up
at me just hand them to you you got that
there you go well we had a lovely meal
but it's getting properly cold now and
Tommy and Rebecca and Jacob all went
home and it's just me and Nathan now
Nathan you excited to do winter camping
but first I'm gonna bust out some of
these adhesive hand warmers and I'm
gonna put a bunch of these on Nathan so
he's plenty warm we're not monkeying
around with this it'll warm up trust me
trust me I'll get super warm you'll be
extra warm in this there you go bud
stay warm we're getting all settled in
for a good night's rest but we need a
lot of wood if we're gonna stay warm so
I gotta go get
a lot more wood these fires take a ton
and if you want a good way of estimating
how much would you need just remember
when you put a two inch diameter log on
the fire it's only gonna last one hour
okay
so about two inches productive diameter
per hours consumed in the fire there we
go pretty healthy pile of firewood there
hopefully that'll last us till morning
oh we've got our firewood we've got a
lovely fire my boy is snuggled up and
warm by having a good time I think this
calls for a little hot chocolate before
bed so one of things I've kind of
noticed it's great about the heat
reflector it acts as a windbreak and
keeps the wind from blowing Sparks and
smoke back into the shelter well it's
about ten o'clock and so far the weather
hasn't been too bad the fires roaring
and we're nice and toasty in here and
we're dressed to the nines but it's time
to go to bed and so I'll see if I can't
get some sleep before I have to stoke
the fire again
I just woke up with ice in my hair and
the fire started going out still very
very sweaty hot but I figured hey if I'm
up I might as well go ahead and not even
cold I'm just doing this to keep the
fire going but I'm going back to bed
well I'm figuring out what I need to do
is have long pieces of wood sitting here
within arm's reach my sleeping bag that
I can do and shove into the fire well I
didn't use as much of my fire last night
as I thought I would and didn't have to
stoke the fire as much as I thought I
would I really only had to get up twice
and the other then I woke up two other
times and just stoked [ __ ] poked the
fire with the stick and shove stuff in
but it is really just cold right now and
it is so nice in bed I soaked up the
fire we get it extra hot and once it's
warm then I'll wake up needed a nice
slab of coffee cake in the morning is
not too bad do you like camping Nathan
I'm glad you I'm glad you went camping
with me this is fun do you stay warm
last night good yeah all right we'll let
that warm back up and then I'll have
myself some breakfast steak
[Music]
[Music]
well I told you I'd do a survival shovel
review and so I used all four of these
shovels here on this trip and definitely
there's some clear winners and losers if
you want a shovel that's light and it
just works really well for digging this
little garden shovel which really isn't
a survival shovel at all is absolutely
the best it's the lightest of these four
it's the easiest to dig with of these
four and it just works really well if
you want one that folds up small little
saag foldable shovel absolutely is the
smallest and it's got the little pickaxe
feature so the problem with both of
these is you just can't use them unless
you're really short or you get down on
your knees now this shovel right here is
some no-name brand Chinese model it's
pretty cheap I think I paid 19 bucks for
it and it's got the handle that that
unscrews and all these little sections
unscrew it it folds down into a little
bit a very tight little package it's got
the pickaxe feature just like the saw it
weighs about as much as the other three
shovels put together this one also has
an edge for sawing and for for cutting
but it's it's pretty dull it also comes
with like a little knife blade and a
bottle opener and some other stuff that
just seems completely pointless if you
want a shovel to put in your Jeep or put
in your boat
weights not an issue get this one it's
the cheapest it works well and it's got
a lot of little features if you want to
go out you know hiking or something or
camping and waits an issue and you just
want to shovel hands down this is it I
mean this is the best shovel period and
it's the lightest if size is really
important then get this if you like to
chop things and you don't really need a
very effective shovel get this I think
the most expensive one here is this one
at $35 so they're all relatively cheap
but I'll put links in the description to
each one of these shovels and take a
look at him and hopefully this was
helpful well we had a great time and we
stayed a lot warmer than I thought we
would it just worked out really well and
I'm glad we did it and we just had a
ball yeah I think maybe things have
blown over we can it's probably safe to
go back home right well it's sad to do
it but I got to pull the shelter down
and and try to put things back the way
they were I just need to take the shovel
fill in this hole little bit and we're
done did you have fun if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys youtube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for watching